all right hey palsies my name is cody
and i'm a helpster that means a monster
who helps and because i love love love
to help so much i'm making these videos
called helpsters
help you
one of my favorite things is to have
friends over and play games but guess
what you can play games with friends
when they're far away too like right now
i'm going to play a game with my friend
[Music]
amazing ally
cody it is amazing to see you ah i knew
you were gonna say that
hey allie please tell these fabulous
people what we're playing today
the game is called scavenger hunt the
way that it works is cody will ask me to
find something yeah and then ally asks
me to find something
and we have to use directional words
when we find our stunts like on or under
yeah yeah or or next to or between
okay you're ready to play ally
so ready great okay so
amazing ally
can you find
something
green
next to my chair is
this plant
ally that is the greenest plant i have
ever seen
you are amazing in every way
fantastic thank you thank you thank you
oh you are very welcome amazing ally
okay uh so so you got you got one for me
oh you ready for this
cody can you find something
made of wood
made of wood huh
let's see
uh whoa
i got a good one for you
under my elephant is
this wooden spoon huh what do you think
amazing nice oh wait a second did you
say it was under an elephant oh yeah
yeah under my elephant lulu
whoa yeah she'd come over and say hello
but right now she's balancing on top of
julian he's a rhinoceros
and they're both inside a rocket ship
because they're about to go into space
[Music]
sounds like a busy day at the shop
not really well anyway that's how you
play scavenger hunt and now you can play
with your friends and family or you can
create a new amazing game yeah you can
well that's it for today but i'll be
back soon until then make sure to help
family friends and monsters wherever you
can
yeah because everyone loves a helping
hand bye ally
thanks so much for playing with me today
hamsters
help you